how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel cinematic
universe and where recently we've been
looking for
and into every single possible clue and
hint that we can find in one vision to
figure out just
who is behind everything that is
happening in the wanda vision series on
disney plus
now there are many different theories
out there of course i have a lot of my
own personal theories but for this video
let's look at what marvel is actually
giving us
what they're trying to hint to us and
what they're trying to actually tell us
in these small little details and easter
eggs because after all like dottie tells
us in one division the devil
is in the details and that's what we're
going to break down today
the details let's go if marvel tells us
the devil is in the details then maybe
they're
actually literally telling us that the
devil
mephisto is in the details after all
marvel stuffs
the little details with super awesome
easter eggs so we should be breaking
down the little details like we always
do of course
now that phrase may have been the
biggest hint towards the devil or
mephisto
being in one division but let's take a
look at other
possible hints and possible easter eggs
for this big
red horn guy let's start off with a new
one division poster that marvel studios
released
yesterday because since it's been
released everybody has been talking
about it because
since it came out yesterday fans have
been doing what we do best
looking at those extremely tiny details
and some fans think that they have
spotted the devil himself
mephisto right in the middle of the
poster if you take a look
right above wanda's head between vision
and agnes's head we can see a wallpaper
background and right in the middle of
all their heads on this background is
what some people believe to be
mephisto and if we zoom in on it it
definitely does
kind of look like a devil with horns but
is it mephisto
it certainly does look like it but does
it just look like it because we're
looking for it would marvel really put
this
so in our face i wouldn't put it past
them plus it is in a very coincidental
and convenient spot right next to agatha
harkness i mean
agnes but it is very coincidental that
it is right next to agnes the person
that we believe to be agatha harkness
and who we believe to be working for the
devil himself mephisto
but let's take a look at some more
concrete evidence
hexagons these things are everywhere and
yes we have been talking about them but
now there's just some new evidence that
we can't avoid talking about and a
possible hint at yet
another villain who could be in the
wanda vision series who is right in
front of our faces
now when we all first started theorizing
about hexagons i took a step back and
thought well are we just finding them
because
again we're looking for them but we know
that marvel does
everything super intentionally and after
all if marvel is mimicking and
recreating old sitcoms in one division
why did they change the brady bunch
intro from squares to hexagons why not
just keep them squares
and why at the end of episode 1 did the
frame around wanton vision become
a hexagon we are an unusual couple you
know
oh i don't think that was ever in
question now we could have shrugged
these off but then
marvel slapped us in the face with it in
episode four in episode four
sword discovered a energy barrier bubble
perimeter whatever you would like to
call it
around westview and this energy barrier
that wanda's magic
or someone else's magic has set up is in
the shape of a hexagon
now that is not coincidental that is
done entirely on purpose for a very
specific reason
now i know we've been talking about how
hexagons are a type of symbol for aim
but i'm pretty sure aim isn't
responsible for this energy field
the reason is i doubt aim has the
technology to magically change someone's
close
and appearance once they go through this
energy field this
has to be magic it has to be the work of
wanda or somebody else who uses powerful
magic
this is also something that agent wu
picked up on as well
he noticed that the perimeter was a
hexagon and on his whiteboard
he even wrote why hexagonal shape so
clearly this has some specific
meaning to whatever is happening in
wanda vision now of course as many of
you know by now a lot of people
are comparing the hexagon shape to
mephisto because it has six
corners and of course 666 is the sign of
the devil and in the mcu the devil is
mephisto
the ruler of the hell realm but there's
also another connection between hexagons
and satan that i haven't really heard
anybody else talk about
and that is a connection that they both
share and that is the planet
saturn now this would be an extremely
detailed and thought
out connection but i would not put it
past marvel studios to do
i mean we are talking about the people
who had jimmy wood do the card trick
that he learned from ant-man
and ant-man and the wasp that continuity
is insane and only marvel studios can
really think of stuff like that
but the planet saturn actually has a
hexagon on it
scientists discovered this in 1981 and
you can see very clear pictures of it
now what's really interesting here is
that saturn is actually associated with
satan and some people actually believe
that satan
is saturn but the bottom line is there's
a connection between hexagons and saturn
and saturn and the devil
now of course this could be absolutely
nothing at all and we could just be
reaching and hoping for theories to come
true
but again why all the hexagons and why
the devil easter eggs why say the devils
and the details and then agnes who we
believe to be agatha harkness say that's
not the only place he's in
now as i mentioned marvel could be
hinting at another possible villain
in the one division series one that many
people may not expect
and again it's leaning on the hexagon
theory but not necessarily stating that
the hexagon means mephisto
in the beginning of one division episode
four we are introduced to tyler hayward
or
director hayward the director of sword
in one of the opening scenes of episode
four
we see monica rambo go to sword's
headquarters and go into tyler hayward's
office
and some people have pointed out that
his pictures are lined up like a hexagon
some people have also pointed out that
his carpet has hexagons on it as well
now if there is truly a connection here
this is very very interesting because
that would mean there are hexagons
within
this bubble reality that wanda and
vision are in
and the outside world but not just in
the outside
real world in the real world in
someone's office who has
a lot of power this could hint that
director hayward has some
sort of a connection to wanda and
everything that is going on
now there are some theories out there
that say he is mephisto himself however
i don't really think that's the case
it just doesn't seem to line up to me
however director hayward could be a
villain in disguise
after this has all been pointed out i am
kind of getting
alexander pierce vibes from him
alexander pierce was in captain america
the winter soldier
he was portrayed to be one of the good
guys being a part of the united states
government
shield and the world security council
but really he was one of the hydra
leaders and commanded all of the hydra
forces within
shield undercover now it's pretty much
been confirmed that shield at some point
moves to sword sword and shield are kind
of the same thing at this point
and if hydra at one point could
infiltrate shield it wouldn't be
too far-fetched to think that another
enemy could infiltrate
sword especially with the scrolls
introduced into the mcu now which is
also a suspicion of jimmy woo because he
wrote scrolls on the whiteboard as well
so could he be working for mephisto
could he be mephisto himself according
to some theories he could be
could he be working for aim and somehow
aim is involved in all of this
there is no doubt that these hexagons
mean something that is very clear now
marvel has made that clear the real
question is now are we actually finding
real hexagons that are connected or are
we simply reaching
it does seem like we have discovered
quite a few easter eggs and hints at
mephisto within the one division series
but what do you think about all of these
different easter eggs that we found
be sure to let me know in the comments
down below and don't forget to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news about wanavision and other
mcu content
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof